DAVID THORBURN: The film
experience is, as I said,
began many years ago, 38 or
39 years ago in the version
that I teach.
And it has undergone
almost a continuous process
of transformation.
One of the ironies is that
it began its career in an era
before there was any
technology available to support
film study.
It made things
actually very awkward.
But it was also in some way
convenient for the professor.
What we used to have to
do was show the film.
We used to-- and
in fact, MIT belong
to a group called the
University Film Study Center.
A group of institutions,
included Harvard and Yale.
And what we did was we had a
library of 16 millimeter prints
of classic films.
And we circulated them.
So you had to
alter your syllabus
so that the guy at
Harvard was also
able to do Keaton because
there was only one
copy of The General available.
So that was very complicated.
And but we all managed to do it.
And then at while I
was at MIT, that system
became moribund because
videotape became available,
and films became
available on videotape.
We also begin to be able to
project them on videotape.
So we didn't have
the problem of trying
to rent the movie
at great expense,
or to belong to the
Film Study Center,
and try to keep these fraying 16
millimeter prints in operation.
So that was a great boon.
It also allowed us
for the first time
to stop and start the text.
So it allowed for forms of
close reading of the media that
had never existed before.
And one of the things it
exposed was the errors
of older scholars
and older critics,
who were working from
memory in describing films,
because in order to write
about a film in the old days,
in the days when I
began to teach film,
you actually had
to project a movie.
And they had scholarly
versions of 16 millimeter
and other kinds
of projectors that
would allow you to
stop and start things
so you could study things.
They were fairly expensive.
And you had to go to an archive
that had the material film.
The advent of videotape
transformed media study
and transformed film study
in ways that are still not
fully clear because every
film scholar, any place
in the world, was able to get
his hands on important text.
And that process is, of
course, been elaborated
an almost infinite
number of times,
a tremendous number of
times over the past decade,
so that today, people could
go online and virtually get
access, certainly to clips,
and to many older films that
were never available before.
And every university,
and every film class
has access to this
material, and can even
set up-- first, as we've finally
done at MIT-- a system in which
students can actually
videostream films
to their own laptops at will.
And that's another
wrinkle because that's
a very recent addition to
what the film course did.
So in the beginning, we would
have a communal viewing.
And it was the only
time the students
could look at the film.
They couldn't even get
a second look at it.
Then we moved to a phase
in which we continued
to have the communal viewing.
But we made videotape
versions of the films
available on
reserve for students
who wanted to write papers
or to review for exams.
And then we moved to a phase in
which when DVDs were available,
we would sometimes not only
project the film from DVDs,
but we would also make
both tapes and video
DVDs available to students
for use after class.
And we would also allow
students to borrow the DVDs
and watch them in
their own time,
and not attend the
communal viewing if they
were unable to attend.
And, of course, that
immediately set in a process,
began a process of attrition, in
which fewer and fewer students
found time to come to
the communal viewings.
This is partly a function of
the scheduling crisis at MIT,
and the busyness
of our students.
If they have an option to
do it in their own time,
they will often do
so, so that what
had been a kind of sacred space
in the course, the 8 to 10
evening slot that I often used
to show the film experience
text became less and
less well attended.
And this had the
also troubling effect
of a slight-- ans I say maybe
more than slight-- but at least
a slight decline in the
attendance at the evening
lecture.
Because the way I
taught the course was
I had one lecture at 4 o'clock.
From 4:00 to 5:00, they
would break for dinner
or their sports activities.
At 7 o'clock, I would give
an introductory lecture.
And at 8 o'clock, the communal
screening would begin.
That communal moment before
the advent of streaming
and before it was
easy for the students
to get access to the
text on their own,
was a much more powerful
moment than it has become.
And so we haven't
figured out what to do.
We haven't exactly figured
how the course can evolve
in ways that can maximize the
students opportunity to look
at the material
in their own time,
but also maintain a sense
that there are certain spaces
ad times during the day that
are devoted to our activity,
just as there are for
their physics lab,
and just as there are for
their chemistry lecture.
We've got to do that to maintain
our parody with the sciences.
When I begin the
film experience,
I asked the students
to do something
they find increasingly
difficult. In the old days,
this request wasn't necessary
in quite the same way.
In the old days, before the
proliferation of smartphones,
and visual media all over
the place, and everyone
being able to make his own video
and so forth, and the ubiquity
of DVDs, before those days, I
was able to tell the students,
look, we live in an
audio visual age.
We live in a televisual age.
I want you to think
that stuff away.
yourself back to an age
before people
understood that there
is such a thing as a film.
And think about the original
meaning of movie is.
Go back to the root meaning.
It's a metaphor that is
a dead metaphor for us.
But it actually--
it tells you what
the most fundamental
aspect of the movies
were for the original audiences,
and why they were so fascinated
by the capacity of this new
technology to capture motion.
It seemed like, and it was,
a tremendous new advance
in technologies of
the representation
of human experience, because
it captured humans in motion.
It captured the
movements of the world.
And the first films, as I
try to show my students,
were so preoccupied by
this wondrous capacity
of the medium, that it's almost
the only thing they filmed.
And you can see the evolution
of the medium embodied
in the way in which, after an
initial profound fascination
with the novelty of
movement begins to wear off,
other properties of the film
medium begin to be discovered.
So I tell my students
this principle.
And I ask them to try
to think their way back
into the attitude of
these first viewers, who
didn't know about
the visual media,
to play a kind of
thought experiment.
Today, it's much
harder to make them
play that experiment
because I have to tell them,
as I do in that first lecture,
think away your iPads.
Imagine a world without iPads.
Imagine a world
without smartphones.
Imagine a world without
instant communication.
And of course, this is much
harder for the students to do.
And of course, at one level
they're much more capable
of processing audio visual
information than I am,
and then my parents' generation,
and all of the generations
older than they are,
because they've grown up
in an environment in which
essentially they're surrounded
24/7 by audio visual stimuli,
by audio visual signals.
Many people might see
this as dangerous.
Perhaps it is.
But it develops new capacities.
And one can see this in
the history of television,
in which at a
certain point, there
are certain kinds of
television programs
that become too complex
for older generations.
And only the younger-- the
cutoff comes around 1980
with a show called Hill
Street Blues, which
older fans, the fans that belong
to my parents' generation,
couldn't watch because
it had too many subplots.
And it jumped around too much.
But the younger
generation that was
used to going to the movies, and
had been watching television,
and had been watching MTV,
or the origins of MTV,
were able to understand
this very easily.
And of course, that
process continued
on television very
intensely sot that today,
there are forms of television
whose audio visual complexity
is beyond the imagination of the
people who were making programs
for the medium in the 1950s.
One irony of this situation is
that even though the students
are very adept at
processing this information,
they are even more
ignorant about the history
of the medium, especially the
history of movies, than ever.
And it's even harder
today to find students
who even remember the
environment in which people had
television sets that required
you to change the channels,
or who had television sets
in which were confined
to a single room, and
which in order to watch it,
you had to move into that room.
So the physical environment
is changing so much.
And of course,
the original space
of the movies, the
great communal theater,
that's a dying space.
You have to try to remind
the students about that.
And so the part of
teaching the film course
has become much more historical.